The Punisher has been a mainstay of Marvel
movies and television for decades.
But there's one project fans never got to
see: Kurt Sutter's take on The Punisher 2,
which was scrapped in favor of Punisher: War
Zone, which hit theaters in 2008.
Sutter, of course, has since become famous
as the creator and executive producer of Sons
of Anarchy, so we asked him for an exclusive
look back at what he had planned.
Here's Kurt Sutter on the Punisher movie we
never got to see...
Not Marvel Enough For Marvel
Sutter was hired to do a simple polish of
the Punisher 2 screenplay.
But he had his own ideas how the story should
go.
He decided he was "gonna mix it up [and] make
it different."
Marvel honcho Kevin Feige didn't appreciate
his tinkering with their characters.
As Sutter told us:
"They're two-dimensional for a reason: that's
the purpose they serve.
So I was trying to expand the Marvel Universe
in a direction it should not have been expanded
in."
Less Guns, More Introspection
So why did Sutter's vision fail?
He explained it was because he wanted it to
be more about character, and less about formulaic
action, saying:
"I was trying to write to the emotionality
of this dude and motivate the absurd violence
with some kind of meaning."
His efforts included writing in a love interest
in order to, as he put it, "explore that pain
through that relationship."
"Who punishes you?"
But Sutter's efforts were at cross purposes
with Marvel's vision for the film.
Sutter said,
"There's only X amount of time the movies,
so you have moments of that, but you can't
really have a subplot that explores that kind
of thing.
Not in a summer blockbuster or a Marvel picture."
Kevin Feige Was Not Amused
After Sutter turned in his radically different
script, he had the uncomfortable experience
of going over it with producer Gale Anne Hurd
and Kevin Feige.
Sutter told us:
"I think they realized what I was trying to
do…and how wrong that was.
So they tried to guide me back, and like I
said, I did another pass, but poor Gale Anne
Hurd…
We were sitting at a big table, and I think
she started glancing over at Kevin, going
'I don't know what happened!'"
Shortly after, Sutter was fired.
"And at the end of it, The Punisher will be
dead!"
Better On TV
The only piece of Sutter's script to make
it into the final version of Punisher: War
Zone was the origin of the bad guy, Jigsaw.
The film was a failure, but the character's
return in 2016 on the second season of Daredevil
was popular enough to earn Punisher his own
Netflix series starring Jon Bernthal.
So why was Punisher more successful on television
than film?
Sutter thinks the character is just better
suited to the small screen, telling us that,
"as powerful a character as Frank Castle is,
there's a real linear component to that narrative,
and it almost works better tangentially, alongside
of another story, rather than standing up
on its own…
That's what you're able to do with TV: you
can go sideways.
You just can't go sideways in a feature.
Not unless it's an indie.
But in terms of Hollywood, the narrative has
to be moving forward."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
version of Punisher is your favorite…